[Music]
what shape are your cells
squishy cylinders jagged zigzags you
probably don't think much about the
bodies of these building blocks but at
the microscopic level small changes can
have huge consequences and while some
adaptations change these shapes for the
better
others can spark a cascade of
debilitating complications this is the
story of sickle cell disease sickle cell
disease affects the red blood cells
which transport oxygen from the lungs to
all the tissues in the body to perform
this vital task red blood cells are
filled with hemoglobin proteins to carry
oxygen molecules these proteins float
independently inside the red blood cells
pliable donut like shape keeping the
cells flexible enough to accommodate
even the tiniest of blood vessels but in
sickle cell disease a single genetic
mutation alters the structure of
hemoglobin after releasing oxygen to
tissues these mutated proteins lock
together into rigid ROS rods of
hemoglobin caused the cell to deform
into a long appointed sickle these red
blood cells are harder and stickier and
no longer flows smoothly through the
blood vessels sickle cells snag and pile
up sometimes blocking the vessel
completely this keeps oxygen from
reaching a variety of cells causing the
wide range of symptoms experienced by
people with sickle-cell disease
starting when they're less than a year
old patients suffer from repeated
episodes of stabbing pain in oxygen
starved tissues the location of the
clogged vessel determines the specific
symptoms experienced a blockage in the
spleen part of the immune system puts
patients at risk for dangerous
infections a pile-up in the lungs
can produce fevers and difficulty
breathing a clog near the eye can cause
vision problems and retinal detachment
and if the obstructed vessels supply the
brain the patient could even suffer a
stroke worse still sick old red blood
cells also don't survive very long
just ten or twenty days versus a healthy
cells for months
this short lifespan means that patients
live with a constantly depleted supply
of red blood cells a condition called
sickle-cell anemia
perhaps what's most surprising about
this malignant mutation is that it
originally evolved as a beneficial
adaptation researchers have been able to
trace the origins of the sickle cell
mutation to Regions historically ravaged
by a tropical disease called malaria
spread by a parasite found in local
mosquitoes malaria uses red blood cells
as incubators to spread quickly and
lethally through the bloodstream however
the same structural changes that turn
red blood cells into road blocks also
make them more resistant to malaria and
if a child inherits a copy of the
mutation from only one parent there will
be just enough abnormal hemoglobin to
make life difficult for the malaria
parasite while most of their red blood
cells retain their normal shape and
function in regions rife with this
parasite sickle cell mutation offered a
serious evolutionary advantage but as
the adaptation flourished it became
clear that inheriting the mutation from
both parents resulted in sickle cell
anemia today most people with
sickle-cell disease can trace their
ancestry to a country where malaria is
endemic and this mutation still plays a
key role in Africa where more than 90
percent of malaria infections occur
worldwide fortunately as this adaptation
thrives our treatment for sickle-cell
continues to improve for years
hydroxyurea was the only medication
available to reduce the amount of
sickling blunting symptoms and
increasing life expectancy bone marrow
transplantation offer a curative measure
but these procedures are complicated and
often inaccessible but promising new
medications are intervening in novel
ways like keeping oxygen bonded to
hemoglobin to prevent sickling or
reducing the stickiness of sickle cells
and the ability to edit DNA has raised
the possibility of enabling stem cells
to produce normal hemoglobin as these
tools become available in the area's
most effect
by malaria and sickle-cell disease we
can improve the quality of life for more
patients with this adverse adaptation
[Music]